Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the one
story that has been most requested over the
last 24 hours.
Donald Trump was interviewed by Piers Morgan.
Trump is soaking wet.
I mean, just dripping, dripping with sweat.
Looks like a rotisserie chicken.
I don't.
He almost looks like he's been seasoned with
paprika and put under a broiler.
In a promo released by the Piers Morgan Show,
it looks like Trump explodes, ends the interview
abruptly and walks out.
Let's take a look at this.
This is a 30-second preview of a forthcoming
interview with the failed former president.
Speaker 5: OK, Piers, I'm ready.
Former presidents in denial be completely
straight.
Your folks think I'm a very honest man, much
more honest than you actually really.
Yeah, it was a freedom fighter.
She lost.
Only a fool would think I do now with, excuse
me, OK, which was the largest increase the
heart of, excuse me, the most explosive interview
of the year.
I don't think you're real.
It's not like this.
Let's finish up the interview Morgan vs. through
a camera.
Very dishonest.
Speaker 1: So certainly from that, this looks
like the interview of the year, I mean, it's
it's hard to imagine anything more explosive
and comical.
Trump dripping with sweat disheveled, telling
Piers that he's dishonest and Piers telling
him this, that it looks absolutely crazy.
It looks fascinating.
The problem is that there is now the claim
being made, and we're still trying to figure
out the truth of it, that that promo is so
deceptively edited that the true nature of
the interview is completely different.
That it was there were contentious moments,
but it didn't end on that note that the interview
went over by like 40 minutes from the 20 minutes
it was supposed to be.
And that mostly they got along.
So NBC now has put out an article which has
Trump releases audio that appears to refute
the claim that he walked out of the interview
over twenty twenty questions.
An audio recording obtained by NBC News appears
to show that Trump's highly publicized interview
with Piers Morgan didn't end, with Trump storming
off the set as edited promotional video clips
suggest.
Instead, according to the recording, which
was provided by Trump spokesman, the two men
thanked each other and laughed at the conclusion
of the interview for Talk TV, a subsidiary
of Rupert Murdoch's News Corp.
Talk TV is set to debut Monday.
It teased the interview billed as the most
explosive interview of the year in a video
summary dramatized with cinematic music.
It portrays Trump as being angry about the
content of the questions.
Turn the camera off.
Very dishonest.
But the audio at the end of the interview
appears to tell a different story.
The two men laughed and thanked each other.
The recording shows there are no signs of
Trump storming offset.
That was a great interview.
Morgan says Trump agrees.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it, Morgan says.
Trump then turns and says, turn the camera
off.
But by then, Trump was already up from his
chair.
So what is the truth here?
I genuinely don't know.
I'm interested in the interview regardless.
To be perfectly frank, my opinion of Piers
Morgan is barely higher than that of Trump's.
I think either is capable of extraordinary
dishonesty and the interview as as promoted.
It seems almost satirical, but I don't know
the truth of that, and we'll have to see it
in the full interview.
What it appears is that little what might
have been done is controversial.
Bits from the middle were edited together
to make that seem like the end, and we're
just going to have to wait and see.
Now I don't let them fight among each other.
I don't trust either of them as far as they
can throw them.
In fact, this is kind of a funny story.
This new show that Piers is doing on talk
TV, which is part of News Corp, is owned by
Rupert Murdoch, who owns Fox and News Corp.
They've been bugging me to appear on that
show.
But here's the incredible thing.
The producers of this new Piers Morgan show,
I don't know if I should be saying this.
I don't really care that they can hate me.
They started contacting me, saying, Hey, David,
we think you would be a great guest for Piers
Morgan's new show.
OK, that sounds interesting.
Sounds like a publicity opportunity.
We would love for you to participate in some
rehearsals for the show.
OK.
I mean, taking time out of my day to appear
on something that's not even going to be broadcast,
I don't know, but I guess if like if it gets
me in front of Piers and I get to know him
and that could still be worth it.
Yeah.
And here's the thing.
It's going to be a rehearsal without Piers.
It's going to be really like a tech rehearsal
for the producers and the engineers and everybody
to like, get used to running the graphics
and the music so it wouldn't air and it wouldn't
be with Piers.
It would just be like a stand in like, OK.
But but listen, if you get on our good side,
we'll have you on the show.
You know, as a guest, when all right, I guess
I'm willing to do it if I just have to, you
know, sit in front of Skype in my in my studio
for a few minutes, they go, Well, actually,
we need you to go to a studio across the city.
Guys, I can't do.
I'm sorry.
And this is how they dangle in front of you
and I. Eight years ago, with other channels,
I won't say which ones.
I fell for this.
Oh yeah, please take time out of your day
to travel to a studio for a rehearsal without
even the host.
And then we'll have you on all the time and
then they never do.
I'm all set guys.
OK?
Everything about the production of this show
seems teeter tottering.
So it wouldn't shock me if Piers Morgan deceptively
edited this, and if that's the case, then
he deserves what whatever is coming to him
now.
That being said, it is not uncommon for Trump
to walk out of interviews because he doesn't
like the questions.
It's actually a classic authoritarian move.
You claim that just real tough interviews
are unfair and then you bail, and then you
use that to justify only speaking to people
in unopposed rallies where you just lie, lie,
lie, and nobody can oppose what you say.
That's a classic Mussolini move.
You can read about that in history, and Trump
has actually done it before.
Remember, he did it with Lesley Stahl on 60
Minutes.
Speaker 5: You're president.
Excuse me, Leslie.
You started with me.
Your first statement was, Are you ready for
tough questions?
Are you?
That's no way to talk.
Snow talk.
Speaker 2: Leslie wasn't one word at this
point.
One of our producers interrupted to advise
about the time remaining in the interview.
Speaker 5: I think we have enough of an interview
here.
OK, that's enough.
Let's go.
Let's go meet for two seconds.
OK?
Thanks.
I see a little.
Speaker 1: Yes, sir.
There's that one.
He also did it during a phone interview with
NPR's Steve Inskeep when he started getting.
They weren't even really like tough questions.
They were just substantive questions.
Trump didn't like it and hung up the phone.
Remember this one?
And one of
Speaker 2: the only way it's not going to
happen again is you have to solve the problem
of the presidential rigged election of 2020.
Mr. President, I
Speaker 4: would like one more question.
I want to ask about a court hearing yesterday
on January 6th.
Judge Amit Mehta, he's gone.
Speaker 1: OK, so the Piers Morgan interview?
Maybe it was doctored.
Maybe it wasn't.
We're going to eventually find out.
But in all seriousness, Trump's inability
to truly be questioned in a serious and detailed
manner by journalists and interviewers.
It's probably part of why the Republican National
Committee has pulled out of presidential debates.
My view is let everybody devour each other
doctored or not, whatever.
Give Trump the toughest interviews you can.
If you doctored the video, you should get
devoured by the press.
These are all terrible people.
I'm talking about Trump here and Piers Morgan.
And I think Sunday, or maybe it's next week,
we'll find out the full scope of what happened
in that Trump Piers Morgan interview.
If you're listening today and you want to
see the clip that we played from that interview.
Just go to our Instagram at David Pakman show,
we'll have it there